welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode six for everyone who's
listening in June 2020 I'm currently in
Belgrade Serbia my dad and my husband
and I have flew here last Thursday never
did I think I would be in Serbia we
probably will be here for the next
couple of months so I bought a tracksuit
obviously because I have to blend in
right so I have my green tracksuit my
platform sneakers I'm ready to take
Europe Belgrade is pretty cool it's kind
of like Moscow and Berlin mixed with
Canada from the early 2000s people are a
lot nicer than Moscow though got a say
which is really Pleasant and I like
Russians but boy they're babushkas mean
anyway this episode I spoke with fasting
expert dr. Jason Fung dr. Jason Fung is
a Canadian nephrologist he's a world
leading expert on intermittent fasting
and low carb especially for treating
people with type 2 diabetes he's written
three best-selling health books and has
co-founded the intensive dietary
management program I had him on my
podcast because I just finished up a 12
day fast that experience is going up on
YouTube by the end of the week fasting
has been incredibly beneficial to me and
is absolutely amazing combined with low
carb diets the clarity of mind is off
the charts there are incredible health
benefits that everyone should be aware
of so hopefully this podcast helps
elucidate some of the concerns people
have around not eating constantly I'm
pretty convinced I only need to eat once
every two days to keep my weight stable
that's a shock even to me that's gonna
be my next test
I hope this podcast gives you the urge
to test fasting out yourself I would
seriously recommend it enjoy
[Music]
hi dr. song welcome to my podcast well
thanks exa Killa nice to see you nice to
see you too I'm a huge fan I've been
like if you know a bit about what I've
done I've been on the carnivore diet for
autoimmune problems and I've kind of
naturally implemented fasting in the
last two years and I've seen some really
good results and I know you're the
basically the go-to expert on this stuff
so I'm excited to have you on thanks
yeah no I'm pretty I've read some of
your stuff I think it's a great story
actually you know I'm a friend of Sean
Baker so he's a great guy as well so
yeah he's done a lot I thought we should
start off for people who aren't familiar
with you if you could just give a brief
background about who you are what you've
done a couple of books you've written
sure so I'm a nephrologist which is a
kidney specialist and so I trained in
the University of Toronto and then I
went to UCLA to do my fellowship and
then I came back to Serrano and I've
been working in kidney disease since
then I wasn't very interested in
nutrition for a long time and started to
change sort of about ten years ago I
suspect because the obesity epidemic
sort of just ramping up so it wasn't a
huge huge problem when I was sort of in
medical school but became a bigger and
bigger problem which caused a lot of
type 2 diabetes which was causing kidney
disease so therefore that's where I
became very interested in that problem
because the whole idea is that if you
have diabetic kidney disease then really
you've got to get rid of the day Phebe's
which means you gotta lose weight and to
treat it with medications is not the
right thing because most medications
don't make you lose weight so therefore
that's when I really became interested
in sort of why people gained weight and
how to lose weight and this kind of
thing and so I went back and I started
to read a lot about these sort of ideas
and most of the stuff that we get taught
which is all about calories is
not very intelligent I mean most of its
just like very simplistic thinking this
whole idea of a calorie is a calorie is
pretty much wrong I mean there are
measurable differences of what happens
in the body depending on what you eat so
if you eat meat for example which is
mostly proteins and fats versus if you
eat carbohydrates for example like white
bread and jam there are easily
measurable differences in how our bodies
respond to those foods even if they're
the same calories so therefore our is if
our hormones are different then our
bodies are going to respond differently
because the way the body gains fat is
based on those hormonal signals it's not
based on this sort of counting like we
treat the calories as if it's some kind
of bank account like it goes in it comes
out but really the body can do different
things if you eat a calorie of food
energy because that's what a calorie is
your body can either store it or it can
use it which one makes a big difference
because if you use it then your
metabolic rate goes up and you don't
store fat if you store it then you store
it as you gain fat in your body by your
metabolic rate has to go down because it
doesn't have those calories
so really the this whole idea and that's
where that's where it sort of came from
so I really started to look at the
hormonal implications and because our
body runs on hormones which led me to
sort of this idea that hey fasting so it
led me to sort of a low carbohydrate
diet and then it led me to sort of the
sort of intermittent fasting and fasting
in general which at the time I started
talking about it which was about six or
seven years ago like everybody thought I
was insane like everybody knew that
fasting was so bad for you as if it
wasn't like been used for the last two
thousand three thousand years but in the
last twenty years everybody sort of
thought that fast and would just you
know be the worst thing you could
possibly do I thought that too at first
until I started
well let me look back at the data and
see what happens to the body during
fasting and lo and behold nothing really
bad happens in fact their bodies are
designed you know to store calories
precisely so that we can use them that
is we use body fat we start body fat so
that we can use it later on it's a store
of calories that's all it is if you fast
you're gonna use those calories of fine
so that's where I started to implement
in my patients because they had so much
weight to lose that once they started to
fast they were able to access those
stores of body fat they started to lose
weight then their diabetes got better
and then I could prevent sort of
diabetic kidney disease so that's where
it all started and because nobody was
doing it at the time we wound up you
know I really wound up trying to get out
there to educate people through sort of
online and YouTube and you know writing
so I wrote a few books about it the
obesity code talking about weight loss
weight gain the diabetes code talking
about how you you can implement it
specifically for type 2 diabetes and the
complete guide fasting which is a much
more sort of how-to guide okay that's
very interesting well I think what
you're doing is really useful for people
especially getting rid of the fear that
if you don't eat for a little bit of
time well good things are gonna happen
rather than bad things are gonna happen
I asked my Instagram a whole bunch of I
asked me Instagram where mainly food
people following me if they had
questions and I have a number of
questions so I thought we could kind of
do this episode as a Q&A style covering
some of the major concerns about fasting
one of the main questions I have is I
have a propensity so I'm ix ur size but
because I think because of my autoimmune
disorder and some sort of hormonal
problem I have a propensity to gain
weight easily like if I overeat calories
from what I assume even if even though
I'm on a zero carb diet I'll store
weight right away and when I fast I can
stay at a stable weight for days it's
amazing like when I first didn't
extended fast I was I had no idea where
my energy
coming from because I was like I'll stay
stable for days and days so what do you
think causes some people to gain weight
so much more easily than other people
even if they're on a low-carb diet well
this is actually true for in all cases
so everybody is quite different so if
you look at the determinants of obesity
it's about 70% genetic so that explains
why you might gain weight very much more
easily than the next person
and we all know these people who can eat
whatever they want and then never gain
weight
so it's it's simply a matter of genetics
plays a big role in that it doesn't
explain whole populations because if you
look at say the population of Canada or
the United States
you know the genetics of that population
don't change very dramatically over sort
of like 50 years so it doesn't explain
the obesity epidemic but it does explain
the difference between one person and
the next and you it's important because
if you look at any diet and no carb
diets are no different if you look at
studies of say low-fat diets for slow
carb diets on average low-carb diets do
better but if you look at the actual
data of how people did there are some
people that do amazingly well and some
people that do amazingly badly on both
diets so on average the low-carb diet
does do better but there are certain
people who do a low-carb diet and they
do horribly they do terribly and there
are people that do a low-fat diet and
they do amazingly well so it's it's very
much individual and it's the probably
genetics plays a huge role in that and
that's probably the the answer so you
really have to find out what works for
yourself which is it may be different
than what the next person does that is
you can put two people on this very same
diet and the results are very different
so you can't say oh this is the best
diet because it might be a good diet for
you or it might not be a good diet for
you and the only way you're gonna
actually know is to actually try it and
see how it goes and how things work and
then it just so fasting for exam
well is probably one of the few things
where most people can't gain weight when
fasting maybe when you eat things
afterwards if you you know aren't
careful you might get late but fasting
by itself because you're not eating
anything doesn't tend to gain weight so
it sort of cuts across a lot of these
diets and I think it should be
considered that fasting period should be
considered no matter what your sort of
what sort of diet you follow yeah that's
interesting I mean I've seen a lot of
people I've seen a lot of people go to
this carnivorous diet particularly the
one I'm doing which is just ruminant
meat and water and most people tend to
lose a whole bunch of weight at the
beginning but some people don't like
some people feel better but they don't
lose any weight and they're saying what
am I doing wrong and it is genetic
differences that makes sense
okay another main question if you do
okay how about this what kind of fasting
regimen do you follow I try to change it
up a little bit so mostly I do a lot of
sixteen eight sort of fasts and I'll say
I don't do it primarily to lose weight
you know I do tend to actually gain
weight very easily just like you but I
do it mostly because I find breakfast a
bit facile mostly all the time yeah I
think I actually have you know I I look
back now and I think you know all the
way back to medical school which was
like you know 2530 years ago I was just
too tired like I just would prefer to
sleep that extra half an hour so that I
could just sort of roll out of bed brush
my teeth and walk into the hospital sort
of thing that is I can get up like five
minutes before I I had to go in as
opposed to getting up and making myself
breakfast and then eating in and then
seeming the dishes and putting
everything away before so I was like
half an hour forty minutes that I'd
rather spend sleeping so I think that's
the reason that I never actually was a
big breakfast eater like it wasn't
opposed to
for any other reason then it just became
a habit and you know it just became like
that so most the time if you get into
that habit then it doesn't it's not very
hard because it's sixteen eight is sort
of what what follows naturally if you
don't have any snacks late at night and
then a couple times a week and it varies
a little bit depending on my schedule
I'll skip lunch - so then I'm into the
24-hour fast so I have a lot of sixteen
eight plus then I get like a couple of
twenty fours a week and then I'll
generally do like a longer fast after
sort of after certain period so holidays
I will sort of just say okay I'm just
gonna eat whatever I feel like and you
know that's the period that I generally
will gain weight I'll gain a few pounds
and my pants will get a little tight but
I know that's going to come so I always
plan to do a longer fast afterwards I
think it'd be sort of two days four days
five days something like that and after
holiday so so Christmas and New Year's
again it's gonna you know I know it's
gonna be a tough time in terms of
staying away from the foods and stuff so
I don't and and so I do a couple of
longer fast and then usually by three or
four or five days afterwards I'm sort of
back to normal and then I'm good to go
so that's that's how it works for me I
mean everybody's look different the
difference is I'm also not trying to
lose like twenty thirty forty pounds I'm
really just trying to lose the three or
four pounds that I gained from the
holidays sort of thing yeah okay what do
you recommend for people who are trying
to lose you know like thirty or forty
pounds how often should they fast does
that depend on the person as well I
think that it does depend on the person
but you also have to find what works in
your schedule more than anything else so
the problem with the longer fasts is
they're really like sort of hell on your
social life's or not that anybody has
much of a social life these days but you
know there's a lot of going out and you
know you don't want to be this thick in
the mud who's like goes to dinner and
doesn't need anything or you so have
like you know two pieces of lattice or
like in the you know you don't want to
be that guy right so if you you're going
out with friends for dinner then you
want to eat so so these longer fats are
tough because they're they really are
difficult so if it's really hard then of
course you have to you have to take that
into account because if it's if socially
skipping dinner with your family is
difficult to do like you don't want to
do it then you shouldn't it's it's never
gonna stick if it's not easy to do so
you got to slot it in to where you can
the good thing is it slots in anywhere
so the key is the 16-8 are extremely
easy to put in because most of the time
you can skip breakfast or have a cup of
coffee at breakfast time and nobody's
gonna even blink twice if you work
through lunch a couple days a week
again nobody even thinks twice about it
so it goes right into your schedule
without much difficulty once you get
past the dinner time and a lot of people
have dinner with their families and or
you go out with colleagues or whatever
then it's a little bit more disruptive
and I think that's that more than
anything else is is the most important
thing because if if you're and we've had
people who would cancel events like you
know for example of fellow would used to
go out to the club and meet his friends
and have you know play bridge and all of
a sudden he'd not go any as fast I like
Linda that's not the point right you
don't want to cut yourself off you don't
want to do anything differently put the
fast thing in where you can so that
you're not disrupting your life so
that's that's probably the one thing so
so 16 eights are very very popular 24
hour fats are very popular because they
sort of slide into your life without any
difficulty and then once in a while you
can make a special point of doing a
longer fast just you know for the back
of it or if you simply skip that dinner
then you're talking about a 36 hour fast
and that is you know you don't go out
every most people don't go out every
single night of the week so you can
easily swap that in too much
difficulties okay that makes sense um
for fasting and you mentioned having
coffee so what's your definition of
fasting or are there different
definitions yeah there's there
it's really a lot of different
definitions of fasting so there varies
on to two things
so mostly fasting the varies the length
of time and then what you allowed during
the fasts
so a classic fast is really water only
and that's sort of the sort of gold
standard if you will you can actually go
higher than that you can do dry fasting
which is not even any fluids but then
not only are you not eating you're also
not drinking which makes things a lot
more difficult like you cannot sustain
it indefinitely that is if you are a
person who has enough body fat you could
live on your stores of body fat for for
most people it's weeks or months but you
can't do that if you don't drink water
so dry fast is not something that is
sustainable for any length of time at
all and you really have to be careful
with it on the other hand some people
like it and if they like it there's no
problem doing it as long as it's not for
sort of more than 16 or 18 hours or so
I've got it you know just inadvertently
like I was doing a 16-8 and I actually
got too busy I didn't wind up getting
any coffee or anything to drink as it
got really busy and so I did a drive
fast and surprisingly it was I thought
not that in some ways is actually easier
than the regular water fast so I have
nothing against it and that's what they
do for Ramadan for example is it dry
fast or not a lot to drink so there's
you know but you do have to keep the
duration down then you go into these
sort of more lenient fast which is
allowing other things in water so if and
everything depends on what your goal is
so if your goal is to lose weight and
things like T for example green tea and
coffee they don't make a huge difference
in terms of you know weight so you can
allow herbal teas and green teas and
black coffee and then you can allow a
bit of cream with a coffee for example
so again you're falling further and
further from the definition of fasting
but you can still do extremely well with
these so there's nothing wrong I mean if
you're doing well then there's no reason
why you
should change change that off so and
then you get some people a bone broth
and some people actually allow meal so
if you look at the five to two diet dr.
Michael Mosley's books he allows during
those fasting days 500 calories for
example and you some people still do
extremely well so there's actually so
it's not like a either/or so some people
say oh does this break my fast it's like
yeah my but it doesn't really matter
right what really matters is are you
getting those results that you want
because remember it's all about the
insulin so insulin is that hormone that
tells your body to sir to start store
and five if you are eating you're gonna
start fat because that's what you want
to do you want to store those calories
if you're not eating insulin it's gonna
follow your body's going to start
burning fat so if you break your fast
inadvertently like say you are fasting
and you take a little bit of something
and like you know it's you know some
carrot sticks and go oh my god I broke
my fast that's like yes you did but you
know the instant is gonna blip up for
like a little bit and then it's gonna go
right back down so it's no big deal it's
not like you're gonna start over from
square one you're just gonna have that
little momentary sort of five-minute
blip where your body's not burning fat
and then you'll go back to burning fat
so it's not a big big deal so people
like to make a big deal about it but it
really isn't and the point is that you
can do all kinds of fasts for various
reasons you can allow all kinds of
things but if you're not getting the
results you want then you might want to
sort of tighten things up a little bit
so not allow the food or not allow the
bone broth or not allow the cream and
the coffee that kind of thing
but if you're doing well then there's no
reason to change yeah that makes sense
I've done I've done a number of
week-long fasts I did a DEXA scan found
out I was like higher in body fat
percentage that I wanted to be and
thought see what a week long fast is
like and I found that the easiest way to
do it
I did like a couple with Oh actually
let's sidetrack that idea sold one of
the things that I found incredibly
beneficial for fasting for me is higher
quantities of salt I've done dry fasting
and that was ok actually it was easier
for me than drinking water for some
reason the shorter ones I'm talking like
20 hours and not talking about more than
that but when I'm fasting especially
doing the longer ones I consume quite a
bit of potassium and sodium mainly and
that seems to help with you know brain
fog fatigue anything that happens closer
to the beginning of the fast that makes
me uncomfortable so what's your opinion
on salt and fasting I think that it's
great I think it works really well for a
lot of our patients as well so we have I
used to see a lot of kitchens in clinic
and and Meaghan Ramos was was the
educator that we had but I can't see
that many people so now there's an
online program called the fasting method
that me and I do and one of the sort of
secrets if you will is solved a lot of
people find it very helpful and some
people will just take salt and water and
it sounds really weird but it seems to
really work for a lot of people so hey
if it works there's no problem but the
thing is that a lot of people are used
to more salt in the diet so most people
eat 3 to 4 grams of salt a day that's
sort of an average and if you go to 0
which is what if you're drinking just
water and tea and coffee you're going
down to 0 sometimes that sort of
transition is difficult so then people
do this you know get a little
light-headed or they might get a little
cramps or whatever so taking a bit of
salt is a good idea so that's where some
people are especially on longer fasts
will say well use some bone broth
because it's not so strange to put salt
in broth or vegetable broth or whatever
as opposed to putting salt and water
which is a little strange but I'll tell
you a lot of people do that and actually
find it very very helpful the cravings
tend to go down for a lot of people so
yeah I think it's a great idea like it's
a strange thing and but it works than me
why not use it right yeah I love it
I love it um do you have recommendations
based on age or is there an age you
should wait before you start fasting or
is there an you know a certain age that
they should fast more or how do you
determine that yeah it all depends so if
you're talking about longer fat so
remember in the 60s when people we're
doing fast they were like not kidding
around if you ever read the studies from
the 60s they're insane like they're go
like 30 60 days the fast thing that's
what the fast was it was crazy because
some of the old studies they would like
fast somebody for 60 days and then give
them a big whack of insulin and drive
their blood glucose way down just to see
what would happen right it was like wow
like I don't know how you could even do
that study people be like afraid you'd
give him a seizure it's like I would be
very afraid but anyway the the
difference between fasting then and now
is sort of the duration so we've gone
away from a lot of these 60 day fasts
and more to these 24 hours so most
people can tolerate 24 hours without
difficulties sort of no matter what age
you are for younger for children
definitely you want to stay away from
anything sort of too long like over 24
hours just because that's a period of
time where they're growing so you really
want to make sure that they get adequate
nutrition and if you're deliberately
withholding food then that's a real
problem now it's more of a problem it
was more of a problem in the 70s which
if you know remember that's at the time
when you had a lot of anorexia nervosa
and you know all these models were like
super super thin so there's a real
problem with that it tends not to be as
big of a problem these days anorexia
nervosa but it is a problem you do have
to be on the lookout for for adolescents
for example and it's a serious disease
people used to die of anorexia although
it's a little unusual now so now we have
the opposite problem so fasting is you
know again it's all about the duration
so if you're under 18 for example then I
would avoid anything over about 22
24 hours you have to remember that most
children can tolerate periods of that so
if you eat dinner so if you go back to
the 60s for example people ate dinner at
6:00 because remember a lot of women
didn't work so that they would cook all
dinner and the husband would come home
at like 6:00 and they'd eat at 6:00 and
then you'd have breakfast at like 8 or
whatever English school at 9:00 that was
the sort of typical thing so if you ate
at 6:00 and you had breakfast at 8:00
that's a 14 hour fast that was done
every single day by virtually everybody
in North America all the children in
North America and if you're a naughty
boy you got sent to your room without
dinner which means you went from 12
o'clock
like noontime until 8:00 a.m. so you're
talking about sort of like a 16 18 hour
fast that people did without any
problems so clearly people are able to
do that and the other thing is that for
a lot of older people they worry about
this and it's like for a lot of medical
procedures we do fast them like if
you're going for colonoscopy if we going
for surgery all kinds of reasons why we
tell people not to eat for the 24 hours
leading up to whatever procedure they're
getting or if they're after surgery you
know the bowels aren't moving so you
don't he can't eat so there's all kinds
of reasons so all the way out so if
you're younger yes maybe not don't don't
go too long if you're older again 24
hours no problem for almost almost
everybody if you're malnourished
obviously then you're not gonna want any
longer if you're very underweight for
example then you're not gonna want to do
that but for most people who are
otherwise okay there's no age sort of
discrimination okay what about so I have
a number of people who are into fasting
for the health benefits having nothing
to do with weight and these are people
with a very low body fat percentage
already do you like what do you
recommend for those people who are are
already
well who don't have a lot of body fat um
again it's it's it's all about what the
goal of the fasting is if a thing
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to be eating less because if you
simply eat more when you eat then it's
it's gonna make up for it so some people
can eat a lot at one sitting and
therefore they eat less overall but that
that doesn't necessarily mean it's a
total and cake of food is going to be
less if you're doing multiple days then
that's going to be problem if you're
very low body fat because that is the
preferred after about thirty hours or so
your body is transitioned mostly to
using body fat so if you have very low
stores of body fat then you really you
know have to be worried about that I
mean these are like mostly athletes and
so on yeah and you do have to worry
about that so in those cases what we
have to do is sort of limit the duration
of fasting and make sure they get enough
to eat when they do eat in terms of
fasting so we do work with Megan
particularly she does work with a number
of sort of top athletes and the place to
use it so if you're looking for peak
performance like competition performance
then fasting you know long periods of
fasting are probably not going to be
great for that but it's great during the
offseason when you're trying to recover
when you're trying to sort of maintain
but if you're sort of in the middle of
the season you don't want to be doing
like a five-day fast or something like
that it's not it's not going to be sort
of optimally it's not going to be
optimal for your performance yeah okay
that all makes sense
what about people who are concerned
about fasting slowing down your
metabolism yeah so again assuming that
you're at a reasonable body fat
percentage or high that's the sort of
cysteine big myth and it sort of is very
strange because if you look at most
diets so calorie restricted diet so the
standard
diet that most doctors and dietitians
sort of espouse is this sort of calorie
restricted diet so the easiest way to
cut calories is to cut fat because fat
is has tends to have a lot of calories
so this is it tends to be this low-fat
calorie restrictive diet and then they
tell people to eat like six or eight
times a day because you got to keep your
metabolic rates stoked it's actually the
very worst thing you can possibly do for
your metabolic rate and we know this
because there's tons and tons of studies
that show that every time you do this
sort of diet your metabolic rate goes
down so metabolic rate is the amount of
calories you burn sort of just sitting
there so not exercise but it's for your
your kidneys and your liver and your
brain and your heart they all need a
source of energy so they need a number
of calories so a lot of people will for
example burn say 2,000 calories in a day
and then when they lose weight the
amount of calories that they burn just
sort of sitting there goes down so
instead of 2,000 calories it might go
down to 1,500 calories a day and that's
a real problem because if you're burning
fewer calories then it's just going to
be harder to lose body fat so they take
that and say well if you if this happens
during the diet then if you don't eat
anything at all it's got to be even
worse but it actually isn't true because
you have to remember that the problem
when you eat these low calorie low fat
diets is that you're keeping your
insulin levels relatively high so
insulin so if you're eating low fat
you're eating tend to be eating more
carbohydrates which have more of an
insulin effect than say dietary fat so
you're keeping your insulin levels
relatively high because you're eating
more frequently and you're eating these
sort of high carbohydrate which is tends
to be high insulin stimulating foods
when insulin is high you actually have
no access to your body fat stores and so
technically we say insulin inhibits
lipolysis
in other words if your insulin is high
your body doesn't burn body fat and
that's natural
remember that insulin is a hormone that
tells you to store
body fat you're eating therefore you
want to store body fat so you don't want
to store body fat and burn body fat at
the same time so so if we take an
example of a person who's eating 2,000
calories and burning 2,000 calories okay
then they try to lose weight the 1,500
calories but they do it with this
low-fat low-calorie diet they eat 10
times a day
they're keeping their instant high all
the time they're eating foods that are
very high in insulin so the body has no
access to body fat stores so therefore
as you drop your intake to 1,500
calories you have no access to your
stores of body fat so therefore you're
going to have to reduce your metabolic
rate to 1,500 there's just no other way
to do it so what if you take your your
daily calorie expenditure intake to zero
that is fast it's a usage fast for 24
hours you take zero calories so your
insulin actually Falls it falls very
quickly like within a few hours they'll
start to fall and as it goes down that's
the signal for your body to start using
body fat so now you've opened up this
new source of calories and there's like
200 thousand calories of body fat
sitting on your body so why wouldn't it
take 2,000 and the answer is it does so
the point is that the the the fasting
changes the hormonal profile that is the
insulin signaling such that you now have
access to your body fat stores and you
can take 2,000 calories so there's no
reason for your body to shut down so
that's why if you look at almost every
study of fasting what you find is that
the metabolic rate is stays more stable
than if you're to follow a calorie
restricted diet so for example there's
one study where they took people they
measured their metabolic rate at day
zero and then four days fasting and then
they measured to get so after four days
of zero food their basal metabolic rate
was actually 10% higher than when it
started it's because you're allowing
access to this new source of fuel that
you've never been able to use before
because the insulin levels were kept
high by our advice to eat sort of a lot
of
white bread and jam and eat six times a
day eat muffins throughout the day and
that prevented us from actually using
the body fat which is why nobody could
lose weight using these sort of diets or
less people I mean some people didn't
this rate obviously but most people were
quite unsuccessful and that's the other
thing that I find very strange is that
like these diets are not like unheard of
like this is the standard diet we've
been telling people to use for the last
I know thirty years that I've been in
practice and it works for like one
percent of people in other words you
have this advice that has a ninety-nine
percent failure rate and we think that
we should still keep giving this advice
and as soon as people come out with
other advice like carnivore or low fat
or fasting or Lokar like we say oh
that's crap it's like wow so the data
xenon your diet bunch here you've got a
99% of failure rate like almost anything
you do is better can't results that we
got with the standard diet so that's
always funny to me that people rag on
you know Shawn for example for his diet
and it's like well like you know to me
he's got better results than most of the
people I did when I was telling people
to eat this sort of low fat calorie
restrictive diet yeah that's because
they assume that people who have health
issues it just has nothing to do with
their diet right it's because they're
doing something wrong in a different way
they're not exercising enough or just
eating too much yeah yeah it's a strange
sort of sort of strange illogic I mean
it's it's very funny to me that we have
this change like so if you look at 30
years you know there you have this huge
epidemic of obesity huge epidemic of
type 2 diabetes and then we say well
it's because people aren't exercising
less like man look in the sixties nobody
exercised like it just wasn't something
you did for fun right it's it's
something it did because you enjoyed
like maybe some tight
but nobody went to the gym and stop that
there was no gems like there's no LA
Fitness and you know the idea of running
you know around the block for fun was
sort of very for and if you ever talked
to like your parents your grandparents
are like yeah nobody ever did bad people
walked and so on but that's about it
like this this idea that we had to
exercise is it's relatively new so you
know to blame that for you know the
obesity epidemic is like to me that's
that doesn't make any sense
it's you know logically just very very
raw yeah they also blame Oh everyone
just started sitting down but it's not
as if people didn't have desk jobs in
the sixties either well the whole thing
is sort of silly too because every
generation always has this oh it's these
young people are like doing this and
that's why they're so screwed up right
so for me it was like oh they have video
games I know as TV and then you know
before that oh this radio is gonna kill
them like every generation has this you
know whatever it is radio TV video games
you know social media is gonna kill them
it's like they're not getting out there
it's like yeah it's ridiculous I think
it's funny because so she had showed me
the you know from the 30s and some
there's all these old guys are ranting
and raving about radio just replace that
with Facebook and it's the same thing
right that's funny yeah yeah for sure um
okay a bunch of people messaged me and
they're worried about hypoglycemia if
they don't eat so their blood sugar is
just gonna add it all continue to fall
so what have you seen happens with
20-hour fasts or extended fasting in
regard to blood sugar so in terms of
blood Sugar's it depends if you're on
medication so if you're on medications
and yes absolutely you need to be very
very careful so assuming that your
on medications then sort of 99.5 percent
of the population doesn't have to worry
about hypoglycemia so the point is that
the body knows how to handle it so you
know we've we've measured this out for
four years so as your stop eating then
you start you know your blood glucose is
maintained at a normal level sort of no
matter what because if it goes too low
then yes you could get a seizure but it
maintains itself in this normal range no
matter what you eat that's the point
like if if hypoglycemia you know leading
to long-term health problems was an
issue then we would never have made it
out of the caveman's stage because at
that point there was tons of days and
weeks that you wouldn't eat because
there was no food available and the
point is that you our body had to adjust
to it so essentially what happens is
that as you don't eat your blood glucose
does start to fall and then it's falls
down to the normal range it gets into
the lower range then your body starts to
produce glucose that is you stored
glucose as glycogen in the liver so
you'll produce that and then there's a
stage called gluconeogenesis where
you're going to use protein to generate
glucose and your body in the meantime
switches over its metabolism to fat so
most of your body can actually use fat
directly so if you have muscles and
liver and kidney they will stop using
glucose when you fast and we'll start
metabolizing triglycerides which is from
fat that is called a triglyceride so and
then your brain still needs to use
glucose and that's why it switches over
primarily to ketones
that's why you have the ketogenic diet
so your liver takes the fat and turns it
into ketones which now can go past the
blood-brain barrier and feeds most of
the brain but brains still need some
glucose but it's not as much as before
and the triglyceride is made up of three
sort of fatty acid chains with the
all backbone and the glycerol can be
turned into glucose so you're not sort
of continually burning protein to get
the glucose that you need
so people are fast and you know like I
said in the sixties is like 30 60 days
the world record for fasting was like
380 days so people's blood glucoses fell
into the normal range low end of the
normal range and then just sort of
maintained itself in that range because
most your body is now burning fat so
Surtur
outside of the brain almost the entire
body is now burning fat directly in the
brain you've got about 75 percent of
your brain using ketones and the rest is
that small amount of glucose that you
need and of course this is how we
survived as a species and that's why you
don't have to worry about bugs because
for most people if if they're not taking
medications the problem with medications
of course is that the medications will
just simply drop it a certain amount and
then you could become very hypoglycemic
so this whole idea of hypoglycemia is
wrong like it's it's just not a concern
but most people need to have yeah okay
fair enough I've seen III go down to
about 70 and stop yeah that's what's
supposed to happen so the you know our
body is so like it's really such a well
designed machine like we think that you
know oh if we don't put muffins in our
mouths every two hours we're gonna like
die right it's like know your body is
much smarter than you give it credit
yeah it has mechanisms to deal with it
and that's the reason you don't die in
your sleep every single night I mean
people like fast for like you know 30
day 60 days and we're worried if they
fast for like three hours I'm like why
are you so worried like I'm not saying
3060 days is what you want to do but
people get worried if they go for like
16 hours or I'm gonna go hypoglycemic
like you can go ten times an amount and
still not even close to being having to
worry about hypoglycemia yeah
okay how do you feel about fasting when
you have a virus or bacteria do you
think that makes a difference to how
fast you can heal from those
it's it's an interesting question and I
don't know that there's any really good
answers so yeah there's a few things in
terms of viruses so if you look at the
viruses when you get sick with the virus
most people will stop eating and this is
called anorexia so you actually have no
appetite so if you have a bad flu you
don't really want to sit down to a
buffet most people actually don't want
to eat anything at all they want to just
drink some fluids some chicken soup or
something like that right so this has
been called and this has been noted not
just in humans but in multiple species
and it's been known for thousands of
years so they've called it the fasting
instinct that is when you get sick with
a virus of some kind you generally stop
eating and it's thought that what
happens is that by not eating you
activate at otha G which is this process
which breaks down all sort of junky old
cells and etaf Egeus actually part of
our antiviral defenses as well so
esophageal you activate these lysozymes
in the in the cells which sort of chew
up stuff including viral DNA so it's
part of our natural sort of antiviral
package so most people don't want to eat
so if you deliberately don't eat like
fasting are you going to improve your
antiviral defenses it's like perhaps
it's not known though as you go longer
there's some suggestion that you can
reverse a lot of the autoimmune diseases
so this is probably if you go out get
out to sort of five seven days or
something so there's a lot of these
autoimmune diseases such as lupus and
crohn's disease and rheumatoid arthritis
and so on where people people's own
immune system becomes overactive and
starts attacking itself nobody really
knows the reason why these autoimmune
diseases exists but there's a thought
and there's a very little amount of data
to support it
that fasting might help sort of reset
the immune system and part of it is that
if your
fasting your body really wants to
eliminate any extraneous cells that is
there's no nutrition coming in so you
have to maintain those cells and having
too many of these cells is is a sort of
a death sentence
so you actually start getting rid of
these extra cells and if in that way you
can sort of just reset that immune
system then maybe the immune system as
it settles down won't attack itself as
much so there's some people who have
anecdotally there are some people who
have really benefited in terms of their
autoimmune diseases so Hashimoto's
thyroiditis is one that we actually
commonly hear people say that Phi Roy
gets so much better I'm like I'm not
sure how that exactly works but it's
potentially something there you know the
few scientists are doing work in terms
of that it's really not there yet so so
potentially could boost the ante by
human antiviral defenses but if you're
Otto if your immune system is sort of
overactive then that might be something
that you might get better as well I
found this was interesting actually so I
found that I've had this same response
to cutting plants as I have to fasting
in regards to autoimmune symptoms but I
was having like psoriasis which I've had
for my whole life I was having psoriasis
that for some reason wasn't going away
on my feet and the difference between
doing the carnivore diet and fasting was
the psoriasis actually cleared up when I
am started implementing fasting so they
arthritis everything else was right that
I was experiencing that went away when I
removed plants and removed things that I
seemed to be reacting to but the
psoriasis went away with fasting which
was really interesting
yeah I mean the plants I think it's a
very interesting area because the plants
you know there's a lot of plants that
people eat and there's this whole area
of Medicine which is sort of emerging
but it doesn't get a lot of attention
which is dietary lectins like yeah
proteins that are sort of taken in and
can be potentially your body can sort of
react to them and there's a disease that
I like I'd study which is called IgA and
Fridays it's it's a relatively unusual
disease but I think that dietary lectins
might play a large role in that in that
gluten you know a lot of people are
sensitive to gluten
and part of that gluten protein the
gliadin people might be reacting to it
so it might be acting as a dietary
lectin that is the glide and protein
enters our body relatively unchanged and
then becomes in susceptible people that
trigger for this autoimmune disease so
dietary lectins are not well described
because nobody really knows if it's it's
real or not and the problem is that with
a lot of new ideas is that not a lot of
people take it seriously so even though
in this disease there's a well-known
connection to celiac disease and i Gina
Freitas I tried to get some people
interested in looking because I'm not a
researcher in this area so I did talk to
a number of researchers saying this is
like a really important thing if you
diet if you can change the diet if you
can study this these dietary lectins you
can actually describe the first sort of
human lectin disease in a subset of on
Gina fry it is like nobody was
interested right everybody's interested
in looking at these immune suppressing
drugs and all this sort of stuff and
nobody was interested in looking at
these dietary things that might actually
help because the thing is that in my own
practice
about 10 or 15 percent of these I
Friday's cases I basically tested them
with the gluten-free diet and a lot of
them actually got way way better like I
didn't need to maintain them on
medications you know so I you know I
present a had a number of cases I said
well this should be studied in a very
systematic manner because then this
could change the practice of this
disease like no interest at all like
nobody wanted to him do it's like that
these are the university professors you
actually have can actually run the
studies I'm not a researcher so I don't
but yeah zero interest was it's just
ridiculous and that was like 10 years
ago and still nobody's looking at it and
there's no bodies it is frustrating
because these sort of new ideas that you
know I'm not saying it's true I just
want somebody to look at it because I
don't have the ability to look at I'm a
clinical you know I'm not a research
around clinician so so I can tell you
what I see on the ground but to do a
proper study is a full-time job like I'm
not gonna do it on on the side like I
don't have the resources or the funding
or the grants or anything so yeah it was
the implants are a huge source of these
dietary lectin so not only are you
talking about gluten which is one of the
more common ones but something called
bovine serum albumin serum albumin which
is yes a wee gluten in so there's all
these lectins that are potentially
important in diseases such as psoriasis
and other autoimmune diseases
you know juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
there's a number of potentially
important things that zero people have
any interest in like you know you look
at the you know there's there's there's
thousands of universities around in the
world and probably zero of them are
looking at this right it's super like
frustrating to me yeah it's incredibly
frustrating when I did when I was trying
to figure out what was wrong with me I
went to an immunologist in 2016 after I
thought I I went to I was in a science
degree and I did a bunch of research on
like IG it was mostly IgG antibodies
and I went to an immunologist and tried
to ask about body's reaction to
potential plant proteins and I didn't
know about lectins at this point
potential plant proteins that could get
into your body through your gut and
maybe that was causing my autoimmune
reaction and he looked at me like I
wasn't [ __ ] and said that's not
possible and it was a top immunologist
in Toronto it was like look like and
then I found out about you know this was
after I cut out a whole bunch of high
lectin foods just by testing it out of
myself and later
you know dr. Gondry's book on removing
lectins is actually really useful if
anybody wants to check that out but I
think part of the reason this plant free
diet works for me is because I removed
all lectins and originally when I
started I was eating a very low lectin
diet and I had amazing an amazing
response with that and then for some
reason something changed and I started
reacting to those foods but I think
there's really something to this lectin
theory that people should be looking
into it's too bad that they're not yeah
and I think that's exactly what's
happening and in a certain subset of
these IJ nephritis people I think that
the lectin which is in this case glidin
it gets through a leaky gut and then in
those people who are susceptible they
wound up with with IG and affright us
which is a disease that's you know
relatively uncommon but you know would
be very important to show that this is
what's happening because that would be
sort of proof of concept that this is
play the role in certain of these
diseases but again like you I you know
despite you know be me be the
nephrologist really found no interest in
and I talked length to this sort of the
top IgA nephropathy well-known in this
field which is you know pretty small
anyway and of course no interest at all
it was just thought something like she's
like interested but not enough to
actually do any kind of research or
think about it much more than you know
past our conversation so yeah it was it
was it was a bit you know
it was a bit frustrating in dawah it is
frustrating because it's an it's an
actual theory that makes sense
it actually makes sense and it means
people's bodies aren't just innately
screwing up like I was told for my
entire life Wow
there's probably a genetic component and
you're just really unlucky it was like I
did not we did not involve for this many
years to just attack our joints like
something else is going on there yeah
yeah it's crazy because a lot of these
autoimmune diseases and I'm not saying
that work for every case of this disease
but even if it works for a subset of
people like the cost is like what's the
harm like yes looking for some type of
diet that eliminates you know week there
eliminates to dinner or little mates
this or that but if you know that this
is happening then hey this is something
that you can do to help people right now
by doing that research and finding out
what it is and that this actually
happens and you know what proportion it
happens in so you could actually build
an entire research career on this kind
of thing but unfortunately as in your
case you get sort of written off as this
one off no it's like okay but what about
all the other people that are suffering
I think you had JRA right yeah I had
idiopathic arthritis quite soon yeah so
how about all those other people who you
haven't tried haven't tried this right
how do you know work for them right and
say you do a one-month trial of diet
it's like what is that what is the real
risk in that it's like I'm weird you're
trying an immune suppressant I know it's
like crazy but then even when you know
and this is what always frustrates me a
little bit about it is that you can have
proof because you know for you it
doesn't matter what people say you found
what works for you
so therefore in you you've proven that
this worked but you're not just making
it up right and
but people say oh that's interesting and
then that's it right it's like well why
can't you like she's supposed to study
this so that you can help other people
because other people won't have tried
what you've tried especially if every
other doctor is telling him that this
diet is insane so but how do you know
they won't do better it's like and the
answer is they don't
and nobody wants to know if it will work
or not like nobody's even remotely
interested is like where is the
scientific curiosity that hey where's
the actual science here yeah yeah like
let's let's it's like why can't we find
out what's happening here so that we can
advance the knowledge in this direction
so that in 5-10 years we'll have enough
information from other people as well
that we can actually change the course
of treatment and maybe change the course
of people's lives like yours right I
mean it's it's it's it's insane that you
wouldn't even want to know this yeah
every rheumatologist you've talked to
probably and every immunologist is
probably like oh interesting and then
not even like my rheumatologist I I and
I was with him for awhile and I said hey
like this is what's happening to me
like this is actually happening to me
even if you don't believe it and it was
interesting his younger intern was
interested but he's in as you know late
50s early 60s and he was just like no
like he he was it so set in what his
theories of the cause of arthritis were
that he he was like there's no way the
diet has anything to do with it I was
like wow might be something to look into
you know for all your other patients
that are suffering you go into the
waiting room and like everyone there
most people there are overweight and
like half-dead with an autoimmune
disorder on a whole bunch of drugs it's
like maybe just try and mention cutting
gluten at least just to see cuz what's
the harm it's very it's it's it's a
little bit like I'm not
you know I'm I'm not surprised that's
that's the that's the problem is that
I'm not surprised that's what happened
I'm disappointed but if you looked at
you know the sort of track record of
these things it's like yeah I'm not
surprised people get into this sort of
set idea and for me it's mostly type 2
diabetes that I concern myself with and
it's like you did the whole treatment
paradigm I think is really really insane
but nobody wants to change it there
ain't it's like oh you eat all these you
know high carb low fat foods I'm like
okay like you know to me it's like okay
if you eat a slice of bread you know
that that blood glucose is gonna go way
up because that's what happened compared
to if you eat an egg it doesn't that's
just what happens we know this wait
that's a fact so why are we telling
people to eat more of this bread as
opposed to these eggs it's like why are
we trying to spike up the glucose like
that's the actual problem and you know
that's gonna happen so why would you
tell people to do that and yet it
persists right you send them to the
dietician and they say you know really
crackers and eat six times a day I'm
like your blood glucose fights up every
time you eat if you're eating you know a
high carb meal so why would you want to
eat six times a day instead of three
times a day like that makes no sense at
all but even if you're to look at it
very simplistically it's like that makes
no sense and it's like people don't care
like people don't even care to think
about it more than that they just said
well that's just the way it is okay and
it's the same for you right it's like
it's not diet it's we need to give drugs
and that's it right like well doesn't
make sense well thank goodness there's
social media
like honestly this stuff spreads at
least there's a community for people who
are wondering about this now
so thank goodness for that
yeah I think yeah well thank you very
much for coming on where can people find
you yeah you can follow me on Twitter
my my handle is at dr. Jason Fung that's
dr jason fun and yeah you can that's
probably where I spend most of my social
media is on Twitter and yeah the fasting
method calm I also that's the program we
use to encourage people and try and
teach them how to fast it's not just the
information because fasting is really
not very difficult but it's really
trying to change behaviors give support
in addition to education and that's the
sort of sort of our goal there because
we can give people information which is
fun but that doesn't necessarily change
their behavior there's a whole lot in
between that needs to happen for people
to do it so so you know being in there
with people who will support you is
really important I mean that's the whole
idea of you know things like the
Alcoholics Anonymous and stuff to have
people who will support you in your
journey and that's how we're trying to
provide there so the fasting method calm
is a great resource as well great well I
would highly recommend anybody listening
to check it out particularly if you're
more interested in fasting I know I'm
putting forth II you know cut things out
of your diet and not everybody's
interested in that but I think there's a
lot of benefit if you want to continue
with your current diet you're stuck to
that with at least incorporating fasting
and so I would recommend checking out
dr. Fung thank you again for coming on
my podcast
all right thank you
[Music]